Speaker 1: I'm going to play for you something
horribly irresponsible. Fox News Dr. Marc SIEGEL
went on Tucker Carlson's show last night, and in a
sort of final salvo to try to hurt John Fetterman,
said John Fetterman is either going to have
another stroke while in office or even will die in
office. He says statistically, he's not going to
survive a six year term as senator. As many of you
may know as versus Fetterman, Pennsylvania Senate
race, John Fetterman suffered a stroke some months
ago. Everything that we have seen from his doctors
and everything we can glean from when we see
Fetterman writing, for example, it's abundantly
clear that he is cognitively fine. However,
the stroke has left him with a deficit in terms
of auditory processing, converting things that he
hears into meaningful messages instantly the way
we all do, and turning what he wants to say into
a coherent speech. He sometimes struggles with
that. And Marc SIEGEL went on and said this This
guy is not even going to survive a term. And I'll
tell you in a moment where where the information
is coming from. And of course, remember that
Marc SIEGEL is not Fetterman doctor. He is
not well positioned to really comment on this.
Speaker 2: Fetterman himself has said that his
stroke was due to a blood clot from the heart.
That is very significant, Tucker, because a study
out of a journal called Stroke, very prominent
journal looking at over 6000 people from Great
Britain, have found that if your blood clot comes
from the heart, you have about less than a 60%,
a 60% chance, more than a 60% chance of either not
living five years or having another stroke within
those five years. It's greater than 60% chance.
So I say to the voters of Pennsylvania tonight
who are ready to check a box tomorrow.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he's he's a doctor,
but he's telling voters how to vote. Okay.
Speaker 2: I think before you check a box,
you should consider a statistic like that greater
than 60% chance that someone like Fetterman,
with a heart in his condition, having had
a stroke, will either have a recurrence or
won't survive the term.
Speaker 1: Okay. So.
Speaker 3: Tucker.
Speaker 1: It's like why
not just I mean, this happened in May. They had
time to put a real candidate in. Okay. So let's
go through this. First of all, imagine if CNN
did a segment like this about any Republican
this just just imagine what would be happening
if they did that. That's number one. Secondly,
where did the doctor get this information? I
don't know. He talks about a British study.
I was not able to find that study. The study
I was able to find on stroke survival rates
is from Denmark, and it did not include
6000 people and included 5000 people,
and it included 5000 people who suffered strokes
between 1982 and 1991. So first and foremost,
it's a period that started 40 years ago and ended
30 years ago. So right away, we should be saying,
okay, has stroke treatment and recovery improved
in the last 30 to 40 years? And the answer is
absolutely. So if again, we don't know what study
he's talking about, this is the study I found.
Indeed, that study does say your risk of death
increases to 60% in the five years following
certain types of strokes for this group who
suffered strokes between 1982 and 1991. Now,
the problem with assessing Fetterman in this way
is that the mortality is overwhelmingly skewed
to people in their eighties, followed by people
in their seventies, followed by people in their
sixties. So Fetterman is 53. So right away you've
got to take that 60% and say this was based on
treatment 30 to 40 years ago. The mortality is
heavily skewed to the 80, 70 and 60 year olds.
Okay. But what's the most important thing here?
The most important thing is that this is a very
dangerous road to go down if you want to just play
statistical games. Let me explain. Chuck Grassley,
senator from Iowa, up for reelection. He's 89
years old. How likely is it? Remember, folks, but
we're just looking at the numbers. Facts
don't care about your feelings. Statistically,
89 year old men, once you make it to 89 years old
as a man in the United States, you're likely to
live four more years. And the Senate term is six
years. Statistically, you can say what SIEGEL is
saying about Fetterman, about Grassley. Grassley
Why is anyone how is this guy? They should have
put a real candidate up. Grassley statistically
won't survive a term. He will die in office if we
elect him. Why is no one talking about that? The
reality is these people know there is no rational
reason not to vote for Fetterman. There just
isn't as isn't even really from Pennsylvania.
He's a moron. He's a quack TV doctor. He's a flip
flopper. But not because his views have genuinely
changed for good factual reasons. It's because
he's putting his finger to the political winds.
So they go after Fetterman character and they go
after Fetterman health in a way where, listen,
if we want to play an actuarial game, there is a
hell of a lot of Republicans who you should not
be electing, because statistically they are not
likely to survive a six year Senate term. These
people are pathetic. And just imagine for a second
imagine for a second how they would be reacting
if CNN did this about a Republican candidate.
I will have this clip and other clips from
today's show on our Instagram, which you
can find by searching Instagram for David
Pakman Show. You can also find my personal
Instagram there by searching for David Pacman.